foreign
[Music]
and welcome to today's webinar how to
improve patient management with
molecular solutions for cervical cancer
screening
and cin23 diagnosed women
I'm Christy Jewell of lab roots and I'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labroots and brought to you
by kyogen to learn more about our
sponsor visit kyogen.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them in the ask a
question box and click Send we will
answer as many of your questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
I would like to welcome our speakers
Anya osterbank valanchek
analysts and laboratory biomedicine
Institute of microbiology and Immunology
faculty of medicine
University of lugonia Slovenia
and vika Kramer resident Obstetrics and
Gynecology Amsterdam University Medical
Center
Anya Vega welcome you may now begin your
presentation
so hi uh thank you for the nice
introduction uh as mentioned uh my name
is Anya and I'm gonna
um I'm gonna show you today the clinical
validation of the new Medics HPV essays
in cervical cancer screening
so this is my conflict of interest
statement
uh I would like to start with 20 30
goals uh sent by who
um so we are uh we have two key
prevention strategies available for
elimination of cervical cancer uh one is
the vaccination
um against human popular viruses and the
other is very effective screening
programs
um that is of course followed by
treatment of detected precancerous and
cancerous agents uh so one of the goals
is that 70 of women uh will be screened
using a high performance test uh twice
in a lifetime uh preferably uh by 35 and
45 years of age
so
um the next question that we need to ask
is what is a high performance test
uh our research group that is led by
Mario pulek has done
um
inventories of commercial available HPV
essays worldwide uh the word the first
one was performed in 2000
2010 uh followed by uh 2012 15 and 20.
and as we can see uh the number of HP
essays is increasing dramatically
and if if we would be in 2010 we'd only
have to choose between 70 HP essays
unfortunately in 2020 we have identified
more than 250
HPV essays and more than
425 test variants so the question which
hvsa to use is not as simple
as we would like to be
um so the main thing that we have
discovered in our inventory is that
approximately 60 percent of hps's uh on
the global market are without a single
peer reviewed publication
and moreover 80 of them are without
published uh any analytical or clinical
evaluation
uh and even more concerning is that more
than 90 percent of HP tests uh
performance performance evaluations were
not in line with standards that are
agreed in HPV scientific community
so of the 600 hp essays that are
currently on the market majority of them
are not suitable for safe use in in
clinical settings
um so from 2009
um
uh we have uh requirements of hbs's uh
that needs to be fulfilled uh so they
can be used in primary cervical cancer
screening
um and the the main uh the main three
requirements are the clinical
sensitivity for cn2 plus that is not
less than 90 percent uh compared to the
Hebrew capture two
uh in women that are older than 30 years
a clinical specificity for cn2 plus that
is not less than 98 of clinical
specificity of hybrid capsule 2 and also
that the essay performance is robust so
the the
uh the the
reproducibility
uh and integratory agreement is met when
compared to the to the standard essay
uh so the study that I'm going to
present today
um it started all in December 2009
um so we have performed uh National HPV
prevalence buddy
for those of you who do not exactly know
where Slovenia is we are basically uh
sitting in in the heart of Europe
uh we are very uh small European country
we have approximately 2 million uh
uh in people that uh are that are living
here and
um we actually have very effective
nationally organized cervical cancer
screening program uh with the coverage
rates above 70 percent
and we have also implemented uh the HP
vaccination
into National immunization program
uh and we offer free of charge uh A3
vaccination with nine uh non-valent
vaccine uh to the girls uh in the sixth
grade
unfortunately our coverage is not very
um very very good it's it's about 50 but
we are um
hoping that this uh this is going to
improve in in the following uh years
uh so the study that I was uh that I
mentioned uh was started in 2009 and we
have invited uh women aged 20 to 64
years old
uh who attended their routine screen
visit uh so we have a total of uh four
thousand and four hundred uh women
and they are representative for
Slovenian population based cohort uh we
have obtained two uh two cervical
scripts one one was for conventional
cytology
uh that is uh standard of care in
Slovenia and the other one uh was
cervical sample that was collected in
pin prep medium all the samples were
then uh elicoded and stored at -84 for
further analysis uh so the colposcopy
and biopsy were done uh based on
based on standard of care uh for insulin
of course linear guidelines uh so they
were performed if cytology uh was asked
us high or worse
but irrespective of that we have
encouraged gynecologists to perform
coposcopy also if women were hv16 or
hpv18 uh positive
so uh for this particular study uh we
have randomly selected around 900 women
that were above uh 30 years old
and we have uh tested them additionally
with pneumodex HP essay
so the original cohort was actually uh
tested with four different clinical
validated hvsays including hybrid
capture 2 kobus and new and
new airports test identity mhpv
um so maybe a few uh words about the new
Medics history essay uh it's fully
automated and high throughput Random
Access platform
it integrates uh nucleic acid extraction
uh followed by amplification detection
and automated reporting of results
it was launched uh two years ago and it
is designed to detect
um 15 high risk HP genotypes uh it can
distinguish HP 16 and 18 and Report
other
13-hp genotypes as for signal
it also have a internal process control
uh that targets uh beta globin just to
make sure that sample is adequate
uh so from our cohort of 900 women we
have divided samples
on which we have assessed separately
clinical specificity uh it
um
this this cohort where uh women that had
two consecutive normal pathology results
uh so that means that women uh were
included with Baseline uh normal
psychology and then uh three years later
uh the psychology was normal again
uh the clinical sensitivity was assessed
on 68 women that had underlying cn2 plus
visions
uh out of uh 900 women we have excluded
27 because of the invalid internal
control which means that in the final
analysis we have included 101 women
um in the
asked in the clinical specificity and 67
women for clinical specificity
uh so first I would like to present the
comparison between Newman dxhv essay and
hybrid capture two as you all know this
is the standard comparator that is also
um
incorporated into my guidelines
so as mentioned 67 women with cn2 plus
were
were included in in the analysis uh and
we as we can see the relative
sensitivity when compared pneumonics
hpv2 hybrid capture 2 is 0.98 and uh
the non-inferiority testing is below uh
this the the Set uh so the the p-value
is below 0.05 which is set for
statistical significance
uh so with this we can check the first
um our uh requirement for hvsa
uh the clinical specificity was assessed
on 101 women uh we have also
additionally genotyped all the
discordant result
uh but as you can see very uh very nice
agreement was between hybrid capture 2
with a little bit more of hybrid capture
to positive result and neomondic states
will be negative result uh but that was
um uh kind of
in anticipated since
um hybrid capture is prone to the
grocery activity with uh with other
genotypes uh overall new movies was
slightly more specific with relative
specificity of
0.1.03 and also uh the p-value was below
0.05
uh with this we have also checked the
the second uh requirement uh and the
last requirement was done
um as interlaboratory uh reproducibility
uh as you can see extremely high Kappa
value was um
who was determined uh 0.9 and overall
percentage agreement is 95.7
uh very similar result results are uh
were obtained in the interlaboratory
agreement uh where we have sent samples
to the uh to the Amsterdam and we have
obtained a Kappa value of 0.86 and
percentage overall percentage agreement
was all almost 95 percent
uh so with these results we have
confirmed uh all the requirements for
the for the new hvsa
and we can
um based on based on our results we can
say that uh pneumonix can be considered
uh clinically validated
uh but we have
um we have set a bar a little bit higher
as well so uh what we have done uh is
that we have compared the performance of
new Medics with other uh
PCR based clinically validated essays
starting with kobas
but as you can see a very very similar
results so practically sensitivity is
the same as the one of kobas
and we have uh
um we have set here kobus as the
standard comparator but the
non-inferiority criteria was met again
and also for the specificity in women
above 30 years old we have very low
percent of discordant results and the
specificity of pneumonics the relative
specificity was above one
again indicating a bit a bit higher
specificity
uh we have repeated this analysis and
compare it to the alinity HPV essay
um again
um the sensitivity of the of the new
Medics was
0.97 and the non-interity criteria was
was met again
uh where when the specificity was
evaluated uh we had similar
um similar percentage of discordant
result uh
yes compared to cobus testing and the
relative specificity was again slightly
higher
1.03 and also the non-inferiority
criteria was met if identity would be
considered as a standard comparator
uh I just plotted the results that I
presented
uh on on this graph just to briefly go
through so on the left side we have
sensitivity and on the uh
x x axis we have uh one minus
specificity
and uh these lines are 95 uh confidence
interval uh lines and and uh all the all
the essays that were
uh that were compared in our study uh
are a very uh similar in in performance
um
so to uh conclude
um
whether I would like to
um send like uh take a take home message
is that a clinical sensitivity of news
for cn2 plus was comparable to that of
hybrid capture uh to kobus and alinity
but the specificity of a slightly higher
compared to all other essays
uh the clinical sensitivity and
specificity for cn2
were non-inferior to those
kind of do
the clinical sensitivity and specificity
where as well and not inferior to kobas
and Immunity
and
according for the inter-laboratory and
Inter laboratory responsibility we have
showed a very high overall
percentage
so with this we can uh we can say that
pneumatics hvsa fulfills the
international
processes guideline requirements and can
be considered
um clinically validated and safety use
in primary cervical cancer screening
um maybe just a thought uh to conclude
uh so we have all been affected by
covid-19 pandemic but maybe we should
seek
um opportunities
uh to
not not only uh to to
[Music]
not only this that we have survived this
but we can use that uh to to have more
efficient prevention and maybe by
promoting uh more uh cost effective uh
protocols
um and if we focus on women that are at
high risk uh and maybe discourage
inefficient policies that are in in some
in some countries in the world uh we
could use the platforms that were
established between the covid-19
pandemic to use them to achieve the who
uh 2030 goals for the elimination of
cereal cancer
um yes with this I will conclude uh I
will just uh I need to acknowledge all
the people that participated in the last
15 years in this study it's been a it's
been a huge work uh and I am very
grateful to all of them uh that we can
have reliable data and and do this
analysis
uh and of course I'm uh if you have any
questions please let me know
so thank you all for listening
um I will tell something about
conservative management of sin 2 and
Scene Three lesions based on methylation
test results
these are my conflicts of interest
so challenges in management of premaling
and cervical lesions are mostly related
to their heterogeneity
cervical screening programs aim to
detect and treat pre-malignant lesions
but not all of these would eventually
progress to cervical cancer
management of sin is based on the
histopathological grading which mostly
consists of surgical excision of cien2
plus lesions
this pathological grading is only
moderately reproducible of about 70
percent
moreover Pathologists cannot distinguish
lesions likely to regress from those
likely to progress causing over
treatment of regressive lesions
particularly in young women High
regression rates have been described
about 20 to 50 percent of centurions in
three lesions regress spontaneously and
in young women up to 60 percent of sin 2
can regress
this is problematic because surgical
treatment of sin is associated with
preterm birth due to cervical
insufficiency
therefore there is a need for markers
that distinguish lesions with high
progression risk to cervical cancer from
those with a low progression risk
DNA methylation markers have this
potential methylation of promoter
regions of genes leads to Gene
inactivation and when this occurs in
promoter regions of tumor suppressor
genes this can lead to the loss of their
tumor suppressive function
promoter methylation of several genes is
known to be involved in cervical
carcinogenesis and methylation levels of
these genes increase with disease
progression
this figure shows a schematic
representation of cervical cancer
development and the heterogeneity within
premium lesions
productive HPV infections can give rise
to productive sin lesions which are
mostly classified as sin-1 or Sim 2. the
majority of these lesions regress
spontaneously when the HPV infection is
cleared with HPV persistence the
infection can become transforming and
cause transforming high-grade cervical
lesions which are mostly classified as
Sim 2 or Sim 3. some of these can still
regress spontaneously
Within These syntuans in three lesions
we can distinguish early and advanced
transforming lesions
early transforming sin 2 and Century
Legions are defined by a less than
five-year persisting HPV infection and
share characteristics with productive
sin-1 and Sim 2 lesions their
methylation levels are low to moderately
high and they have only few copper
number alterations they often have the
HPV E4 expression and no or very low
staining of B16 and ti-67
Advanced transforming symptoms three
lesions
are defined by a more than five-year
persistent HPV infection and shared
characteristics with server called
cancer they have a cancer-like
methylation profile with very high
methylation levels they have many copy
number alternate alterations no HPV E4
expression and high p16 Ki 67 levels
we distinguish these productive low
breaks in one lesions and about 50
percent of the sin two lesions are like
these productives in one lesions they
have low methylation DNA methylation
increases with lesion severity and is
extremely high in cervical cancer and
that's why we think they can be of
interest for management of sin 2 and
syn3
um over the years several methylation
essays have been this
covered and essays have been developed
and they have been evaluated in cervical
cancer and premalignant lesions
these are some commercial essays that
exist and they are developed for triage
tests of high-risk HPV positive women in
cervical screening most research has
been done with the kyoshier methylation
test which tests for methylation of
thumb 19a4 and mere 124 too it's a PCR
Multiplex and it's validated for both
self-samples and cytology samples
the Kaiser methylation test measures
methylation of these two genes
and is a CE ivd registered kids like I
said it's a quantitative Multiplex
methylation specific PCR it's applicable
on self-samples and also cervical
scrapes and it has an automated data
analysis and objective readout
the essay has been developed for triage
of high-risk HPV positive women in
cervical screening and has been
evaluated in various screening settings
in two large trials conducted within the
Dutch screening program it showed good
clinical performance for the detection
of syn3 plus which is comparable to that
of cytology as shown here in the table
it has also been validated
in a European screening setting within
the valid screen project using samples
of over 2 000 high-risk HPV positive
women aged 30 years and above the
sensitivity for scene 3 was 77 and
sensitivity for cervical cancer was 95
percent
approximately 50 percent of sin 2
lesions were detected in this study
um the test has also shown very good
sensitivity for cervical cancer
um in a large worldwide series of
cervical carcinomas 98 tested
methylation positive
this slide shows the performance of the
methylation assay in high risk HPV
positive self samples these are from a
Dutch trial the protect trial which
tested 633 HPV positive cell samples and
as you can see it showed good
performance for cn3 plus detection with
sensitivity of 70 and specificity of 68
and also in this study all cervical
carcinomas were detected
this shows the long-term safety for
methylation analysis compared with
cytology this was 15-year follow-up data
from The poboscom Trial showing the
cumulative cancer incidents HPV positive
women with a negative methylation test
at Baseline represented by the black
line had a lower long-term cervical
cancer risk compared with cytology
negative women represented in the green
line
we also evaluated the long-term safety
for scene 3 and showed that a negative
methylation test provides a similar long
term syn3 plus risk in HPV positive
women compared with a negative cytology
test
more recent data show that methylation
can also predict clinical outcome
luvanto and colleagues show that the
positive methylation result with the S5
classifier predicts regression
progression of syn2
um hample and colleagues then evaluated
from Mere methylation in a retrospective
series of samples from pregnant women
with cervical cancer progressives in
three regressive syn3 and no sin and in
this study the likelihood of cervical
cancer or Progressive sin 3 in women
with a negative methylation test was
Zero
and what I'll tell to you about in more
detail is the conserved study and in
this study we showed that untreated
sintuits in three lesions with a
negative methylation test have a very
high spontaneous regression rates
so here you see the methods of the
conserve study it was a study conducted
in the Netherlands and included 114
women diagnosed with sin 2 and sin 3 on
a cervical biopsy
these lesions had to be smaller than 50
percent of the cervix and women were
managed conservatively with six monthly
follow-up visits for a period of two
years
at Baseline and during each follow-up a
self-sample a cytology sample were
collected and colposcopy was performed
women who showed clinical progression
during the study received surgical
treatments
progression was defined as exceeding the
volume of more than 50 percent the same
two that became a sin 3 or a Scene Three
that became cancer
and also when the transformation Zone
was not visible women had a treatment
indication
the detection of adenocarcinoma in situ
was also a reason to stop the study and
have a treatment
study endpoint was absence of sin 2 plus
on histology or hbv negative normal
cytology sample
this slide shows the Baseline
characteristics of the study
as you can see we included mostly Sim
two lesions eighty percent uh sorry 70
of women had a Sim 2 and 30 percent had
same three
women were included mostly after 30
years old because this is the screening
age in the Netherlands but we also had
31 women who were under 30 years old
they were referred because of
inter-menstrual bleeding for example
we mostly included smaller lesions so
um 70 of all lesions were smaller than
25 percent of the cervix
about 50 of women were initially
referred with high grade cell cytology
the Baseline methylation test was
positive in uh 46 and negative in 52
percent and here you can also see the
HPV genotyping results showing that 50
of the women tested positive for hpv16
so this slide shows the
Kaplan Meyer analysis for endpoint
regression and as you can see is that
methylation negative women showed more
regression compared with methylation
positive women
75 compared to 51
we found similar results in smears and
in cell samples
and regression rates were not associated
with same grades
this uh
slide shows the combination of cytology
with methylation and cytology with
hpv-16 genotyping
um cytology by itself was not associated
with clinical regression but combined
testing with cytology and methylation or
hpv-16 was so in the left figure you see
the combined effect of cytology with
methylation and as you can appreciate in
women with askers or low sales cytology
methylation was significantly associated
with regression 88 of women with s has
low sale and the negative methylation
test this is the top blue line showed
clinical regression
in women with high grades cytology these
are the dashed lines methylation was not
associated with regression
for hpv16 we found the opposites
hpv-16 was nearly significant associated
with regression in women with high-grade
psychological abnormalities but not in
women with askers or low cell
we also evaluated the combination of
methanation with hbv 16 genotyping
we found highest regression rates for
hpv-16 negative and methylation negative
lesions this is the top dashed Blue Line
85 percent of those women regressed
HPV 16 positive and methylation positive
the blue the sorry the red line showed
lowest regression
intermediate regression rates were found
for women who tested either positive for
methylation or hpv16
this shows that com there is a
complementary effect of hbv16 genotyping
and methylation
so with the concert study we showed that
you can use the pie Shear methylation
testing management of women with sin 2
and sin 3.
um women who are diagnosed with sintu
and sin 3 and who wish to preserve their
fertility they could be tested for
Kaiser and if they test negative this
can reassure the clinician in active
surveillance
um kayasher positive women could be
advised to have excisional treatments
another application for the kayashir
methylation test is a triage marker of
HPV positive women with low-grade
cytology or escis with the introduction
of HPV screening in the Netherlands we
saw an increase in colposcopy referrals
particularly of women with askers and
low cell triage of these women with
methylation assay could reduce this over
referral and only women with a positive
methylation essay should be referred for
colposcopy negative women could be
re-screened after one year
you could also use a combination of
eska's low cell triage of kayasher with
hbv 1618
in which case if women are in double
negative for kayasher and HPV 1618 the
advice would be to rescreen within three
years a positive kai-share test would be
direct referral for colposcopy and HPV
1618 positive but kayasher negative the
advice would be re-screen after one year
this application is supported by recent
data from a post-hoc analysis within the
proboscum and fusa Screen trials which
showed that the use of methylation can
reduce the number of colposcopies
periods of high-risk HPV positive women
with low-grade cytology using
methylation could reduce the colposcopy
referrals by 60 while maintaining
assessment sensitivity forcing three of
about 70 percent
using both partial genotyping and
methylation led to a further reduction
in copposcopy referrals depending on the
extent of genotyping using only 16 18 or
16 18 31 33 and 45 up to 25 reduction in
referrals
these figures showed us in three plus
risk following a negative or positive
triage test with either methylation or
1618 genotyping or the combination on
the right
the first figure illustrates that
methylation negative women have an
acceptable syn3 plus risk supporting
re-screening after one year methylation
negative women have seen three plus risk
of about 10 percent
hbv 16 18 negative women have a slightly
higher Sim 3 plus risk of about 13
percent
and the lowest Sim 3 plus risk is among
women with a negative methylation and
the negative HPV genotyping test 6.5 of
those have seen three plus
so the last application I already showed
in the beginning of my talk would be
triage of high risk HPV positive women
in cervical screening which could be
performed on self samples or on cervical
scrapes and all HPV positive women could
be tested with kayasher if they're
positive they should be referred for
coposcopy and if they're Negative they
should be rescreened within three years
and referred Fork aposcopy if they are
persistingly positive for HPV
also here there is an option of
combining that with 16 18 genotyping
so to conclude
um I've shown you that the Kaiser
methylation test can be used for
management of women with sintu and sin 3
and can prevent over treatment and harm
when negative this supports a
conservative therapy which is especially
important in young women
can also be used for triage of HPV
positive women with askers or low sales
cytology and prevents over referral and
over treatment when positive it should
instigate copposcopy referral when
negative it gives a high reassurance
against cervical cancer
and lastly it can be used as triage
marker for HPV positive women in
cervical screening and it is an
alternative to cytology which is
objective reproducible and can be
performed on a cell sample
with this I'd like to thank you for
attend your attention and I'd be happy
to take any questions
thank you Anya and vika for your
informative presentation we will now
start the live q a portion of our
webinar now to our audience if you have
any questions you would like to ask
please do so now just click on that ask
a question box located on the far left
of your screen and we will answer as
many of your questions as we have time
for okay we have quite a few questions
coming in already so let's start here
um but vika this question is for you
do you think the assay is ready for
clinical use and how do you think it
should be used in clinical practice
thank you Christy
um and thank you for this question
um I think the essay is ready for
clinical use by gynecologists for
example who are doing coposcopy
especially as we see quite a few young
women who are referred with HPV positive
and minor abnormalities on cervical
biopsies
they're often followed up for a long
period of time and often they receive
treatment which can cause preterm birth
in subsequent pregnancies so I think in
especially in younger women like under
the age of 40 the methylation can really
help to direct clinical Management in
younger women so if the methylation is
negative
it can support a wait and see policy in
which you could say someone who's
diagnosed with a sim2 or a scene three
you do follow up after six months up to
one year to do coposcopy again to see
whether the lesion is going to regress
or not
thank you vika Anya let's go with this
question for you
was assay evaluated on sure path samples
as well
uh yes I I haven't showed this data
because the analysis was done elsewhere
but uh yeah it was it was published
actually together with our data
uh I think that approximately 1
000 women were included in that study
um the pneumatic City essay was compared
to the HPV risk essay from cell screen
um and the non-inferiority testing
showed that the clinical sensitivity and
clinical specificity uh met uh met the
the threshold that that they need to so
yes we can I can I can confirm that the
essay is also validated on uh this this
type of samples so it cannot be used uh
I mean it can it can be used with either
of the medium
thank you Anya Pika let's come back to
you for this next question
did you separate did you do separate
analysis for sin 2 and sin 3.
yes thank you so in the conserved trial
we had 114 women of whom 34 had a sin 3.
so we had relatively small numbers I've
seen three for uh separate analysis but
we did do that uh separately and we saw
that in both scene two and in scene
three methylation negative women have a
higher uh recurrence uh sorry a
regression rate compared to to the
methylation positive so both in sin 2
and sin 3 we found a significant
Association
thank you vika and Anya it looks like we
have one more question and we'll um take
this question for you
is partial HPV 1618 genotyping important
in real life clinical practice
um yeah thank you uh for the question uh
I I this could be a title for a new
webinar but uh to make it short
um yeah I I feel that uh genotyping is a
very nice way uh for the triage
uh but I think that we are not quite
there to determine which genotypes
should be uh should be
separately identified I'm I'm I know for
firm believer that
um the genotyping information is
valuable valuable only in in the case
that it affects clinical practice
so if the
genotyping results is based on the risk
that each genotype carries with it I
think that yes then definitely we should
use genotyping information but I think
it should be uh risk based so
um yeah it's it's in short yes I think
it's important but in in Long uh version
uh it's it's
a completely new session
thank you Anya and thank you vika too
for your time today and your important
research do either of you have any final
comments for our audience today
I just thank you for being here
yeah I also don't have any further
comments so thanks for listening
absolutely well thank you for joining us
and we appreciate all the time and
efforts that you're putting into this
research we also want to thank lab roots
and we would like to thank our sponsor
kaijin for underwriting today's
educational webcast
before we go I also would like to thank
the audience for joining us today and
for their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and additionally those questions that
are submitted during the on-demand
period they will be addressed by our
speakers via the contact information you
provided at the time of registration
today's webcast can be viewed on demand
and lab Roots will alert you via email
when it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
thank you for joining us until next time
take care and goodbye